welcome to the program we begin in
Ukraine where Russian missiles have
struck the Western city of leviv killing
at least four people the region had been
relatively calm since it's away from the
main front lines the regional Governor
says around 60 apartments and 50 cars
were hit in Satellite dozens of people
are said to be injured and the death
toll is expected to rise hundreds of
thousands of ukrainians have sought
safety in leviv let's bring in Rob
McBride now who joins us live from the
capital Kiev hello there Rob what's the
latest coming out of that Western
Ukrainian City
yeah this does seem to be a significant
attack in the very west of the country
and particularly in the city of the Vive
in a college District of that City a
number of buildings and dormitory
buildings have been badly damaged and in
particular one residential complex right
in the center seemed to have borne the
brunt of this strike with the top floors
uh completely destroyed the death toll
now stands at four people killed with
dozens of others injured throughout the
hours of Darkness throughout the
nighttime rescue teams have been there
looking for any survivors pulling
injured from under the rubble uh the
mayor of leviv Andrew sadovi on his
telegram channel has said that this is
one of the worst attacks on civilian
infrastructure in the Viv since the War
Began and certainly it's true that while
leviv is a very important Regional
Center for the for the west of the
country in important Logistics Hub with
its proximity to the Polish border with
Communications in and out of the UK
brain it has avoided much of the
destruction that other cities have seen
it's hundreds of kilometers away from
any front line it does not often get
attacked and very rarely residential
buildings like this uh are destroyed in
such in such a way according to the
Ukrainian military overnight a total of
a 10 caliber missiles were fired by the
Russians from submarines and warships in
the Black Sea seven of those being
intercepted and Rob in another
development Ukraine's military is
claiming to have carried out a
significant strike in the east of the
country possibly destroying a Russian
military base what more are you hearing
about that
yeah this is video which has been
circulating on social media that's now
been released re-released by Ukrainian
military showing an attack on the city
of makiefker outside of Donetsk
russian-controlled City uh that a series
of the big explosions followed by a huge
blast and a fireball as often is the
case uh both sides while accepting this
has taken place there are conflicting
reports about exactly what we are seeing
here according to the ukrainians this
was a russian-based and ammunition a
storage dump which would seem to be
borne out by the pictures of exploding
ammunition according to the Russians
this was a civilian area that was
attacked they say one person was killed
and dozens more civilians were injured I
think the point the ukrainians are
making uh with this with announcement of
this attack is that you know while any
progress on the front lines of this
conflict since the long-awaited
counter-offensive is several weeks in
has begun the progress seems to have
been extremely slow we've not been
seeing the kind of breakthroughs that
maybe many had predicted and they want
to make the point that their campaign of
a targeting Russian targets Uh Russian
resources way behind Russian front lines
of headquarters groups of logistics hubs
fuel dumps and all the rest that that
continues and despite Russian claims
that they are repelling that this
counter-offensive the Ukrainian point is
that gradually they are weakening the
Russian forces all right thanks so much
for the update as always Rob McBride in
Kiev